日本語で根ですか 根因なんですけど
なんか根因って言ったらわかりませんね
まあだから語根はわかりますね
眼耳鼻舌身という インドでは英語で言えばこのfacultyという
まあ窓口みたいな意味なんですね
窓口とは 例えばまあまあ
いろいろ事務所とかいろんなところにいろんな仕事をする窓口あるでしょ
そんな感じで で 例えば目
1つこの視覚を作る窓口であって
目から入るものは頭の中で視覚として調節する
鼻から入るものは香りとして調節する
ですから窓口なんですね
で そこでインドリヤ・パッチっていうのはもうなんでパッチになるんでしょうかね
ここら辺私もわかりません
で インドリヤというのは眼耳鼻舌身意という六つだけじゃないんです
24あります バギセテ・インドリヤニという風に書いてますからね
例えばサッダ・サティ・ヴィリヤ・サマーディ・パンニャーもインドリヤなんですね
身 念 精進 定 慧 そういうのもあの窓口としてあるし
で こちらも6つあります
そこでこれは説明してたはずなんですが
どこかで インドリヤというところは
その前どこかで出てきたんでしょう
サンガ  22ありますね
それあの213ページにはあります
214ページに日本語訳入ってます
で だから22の窓口があります
窓口で言ったってわかりにくいんですけど
で  そのその22種類のものが条件としても働くんだと
で わかりやすく言えばね
例えばサティというものがありますね
皆様がよく知っているサティ
念というもの そういうのは我々にはいつでもあります
サティっていうのは瞑想する時だけあるものじゃなくて
常にいつでもあるものなんです
いつでも いつでもあるものなんですけど
わざとこのサティという我々持っているそのものを瞑想としていじってるでしょうに
そうすると そのサティっていうのは力強くなるということもありますね
それ力強くなったら 次の式の認識が変わるんです
だから前の認識が次の認識を必ず作る
前の認識には必ずサティもあります
だからそれは 2番目の認識に影響を与えているんです
その場合は原因と結果だけで
そこで前の認識のサティはちょっといじってるんだと
そうするとこちらのサティに次の認識にはいくらかの変化が起こるんですね
ということだと思います
で まあ本当は説明できますけど
そこに行ったらこれ何年かかるかわからないんです
これパッターナのテキストっていうのはすごいたくさんあるんです
アビダルマの中で一番長いパッターナなんです
ものすごい長いんです
今までこの心相とかこころとうか書いてるアビダルのテキストっていうのは
普通の印刷するテキストはこれぐらい
まあ 1センチぐらいでもならないほど小さいんです
パッターナの場合は2 3
冊 ですから そこら辺は説明しすぎちゃうと
もう 私はそこら辺ちょっともうサボるんだからといって
別にもう仏教理解には何の影響もないんです
だからそこら辺ですからね
とにかく二十四種類のものがあって
インドリーヤといって根というんですね
次にあるのは何でしたっけ？禅
ジャーナ ジャーナは禅のことで禅ということで禅定の禅ですね
定ですね 禅といったって
それの原因ではなくて条件になるんだと
そこはこれ禅定とか何とかと言ったっても
そんなに大変なことではなくて
もう一つの認識なんです
瞬間瞬間 我々は物事を認識している
その働きは消えるわけじゃないんですね
死んでも認識っていうのはもうかわいそうに
心が死んじゃったら心が現れる法則だから
また現れちゃうんですね
そこで私が生まれ変わったんだよと探したって見つからないんで
私がどこにもないんだから
アイデンティティもまるっきりないんだからね
それを見つかりません
でも宇宙的なエネルギーとして
やっぱりもう消えることなく続けてしまっちゃうという大変悲しいことはあるんですね
それで悲しいことというのは確かに悲しいことなんです
別にちょっと余計な言葉で言っているわけではないんです
仏教ではそれは悲しいことだと思っているんです
終わりなく続くことは
で 物事を認識する場合は
その瞬間 それに集中しないと見えないんです
見えるといったって認識できないんですね
だからあんまりにも力弱いんですね
だから我々持っているこの集中力っていうのは
ただ認識するできるぐらいの一番最低のレベルで持っているんです
統一性っていうのは 見るっていうことは見るっていうことだから
そこで十分だと思っちゃうんですね
思っても だから次の瞬間には音を聞くと
仏教と他の宗教でも同じことを言っています
それだけでは足りませんと
ちょっとちらっと見ただけで見たわけにはならないんだと
もっと集中して見なさいと
そうすると集中 それがするほど前見たものとは違うものを見るでしょ
それから女性の方を遠く見ると側に見るとと同じ
だから明確に見れば見るほど視覚が変わっていっちゃうんですね
[笑い]ですから この
まあ一般的に言えば明確に見た方がより正しく見えるだろうということにはなるし
だからどこまで明確に見ればより正しく見えるかということにはキリがないしね
だから例えば遠くから見る
近く見る 虫眼鏡で見る
顕微鏡で見るとかね それで見る見るエネルギーは強くすればするほど見えるものが変わっていっちゃうんです
だからどちらが正しいかということははっきりと決めることはできませんしね
最終的に電子顕微鏡で見ると
今の見えるものは全部なくなっちゃうんですね
原子だけで見えてしまっちゃうんです
原子だけで電子顕微鏡で見えるんだけど
もうさらに倍率を上げて見るんだったら
もっと違うものを見えてしまうし
だからこの明確に見れば見るほど
やっぱりより正しいものを見ることは確かなんですね
そちらはもうもうキリがないんですね
やっぱり だからこの場っていうのは統一性なんです
私たちは自分勝手にこれでいいという思ってるぐらいでしかサマーディの力を持ってないんです
それは誰にでもあるんです
だからこの面白いんです
猫とかね 人間よりすごいサマーディの能力あるんです
猫なんかこの獲物なんか見たらもう体が硬直するんですね
止まっちゃうんです あのあれしか見えません
その時呼んでみてください
聞こえないんです そこで言う足とかね
これ上げてちょっと待っていて
またゆっくりこうやって持っていって
それゆっくり下ろして
瞑想するヴィパッサナーと同じことやってる
すごいスローモーションです
だから自分が飛べる適当な距離になるまで
すごくこの時々しゃがんでね
歩いたりもしていたりするし
やっぱりその場合は本当に集中力あるんです
だからこのその自分のわがままで
好きな仕事に好きなぐらい集中力を入れるということはいつでもあることで
そこはわがままでやってるんだから
そこは成長にはつながりません
だから瞑想しなくても
人はね いろんな分野で集中力を育てるんです
ですから まあまあ それはそれで
だからって それは人の人格成長につなげるかかってそうはつながりません
それわがままだから やりたいんだからそれやってるんであって
だから猫にもそれあるし
犬にもあるし 日本では見られませんだけど
例えば犬二人が喧嘩している時と自分飼ってる犬だからと思って仲介に行ってみてください
噛まれちゃうんです 自分の犬に
その場合は決してこの犬が自分の飼い主を噛んだわけじゃないんです
飼い主を噛みついたわけじゃなくて
もう喧嘩に徹底的に集中しているんです
ただそれだけ すべて忘れていて
とにかく噛む それだけ
何でも噛むと 私もそれ噛まれたことがありますから
仲介してよと思って ですから
この そういうふうに集中力は禅のことであって
だからそこ生まれたら次の次の心の認識がそれの影響で変化するんですね
だからそれ条件として原因でもあって
だから条件というものは別に存在するものではないんです
普通の方そのものなんですね
物質と心と心相 そういうものから
次の物質と心相とやら心が生まれるのであって
そこで原因と結果の話であって
そこでこの原因になる物質心の中で
いくらかいくらか特別になんとなく変化に影響を与えちゃうんですね
ただそれだけで条件論を語っているんです
サマーディの場合は まあこれアビダンマの世界だから
私が言ってるこの犬のサマーディとか猫のサマーディは考えてないんですけどね
まあこちらで考えているのは
この瞑想している人々のサマーディなんですね
禅定なんですね これ禅定作ったら一旦禅定作ったら
その人のそれからの認識は変わっちゃうんです
例えば一旦禅定を作ったとする
それからその人はものを見たら
あ 面白いとかね あ すごい美味しいものを見っけたと
じゃあ食べようとか そういうふうに欲やら嫌なことを見たんだからといって怒ったりとかね
そういうものは生まれません
サマーディの力で 次から次へと見たり聞いたりするものに対して
欲も怒りも生まれてこない
そこでサマーディの力で昏眠とか抑えてしまっちゃいますから
普通の人よりは元気で明るく活発的になっちゃう
そういうサマーディには特別力があるんですね
そういうふうに影響を与える
一旦瞑想してサマーディが生まれた人は
それからこのサマーディ上ということ
壊れて また欲に溺れない限りは
思考方向性は変わるんです
ものを見ても欲が出てこないし
怒りもそんなに出てこないし
混乱もないし 悩みもないし
落ち着いているし それで昏沈睡眠もないし
寝ないってわけじゃなくて
寝るんだけど いつでも昏沈睡眠で悩んだりとかね
そういうこともない その代わりに
すごくいつでも明るく
活動的で 心が活発に動いているんです
すごく明るいんです ものすごい元気なんです
だから瞑想すればするほど暗くなって暗くなって
なんか社会から逃げて逃げて逃げて消えて消えて小さくなるんだったら
それは仏教の瞑想法ではないんです
これ心を育てることだから
今も心のエネルギーで生きているんだから
心のエネルギーを育てるということはどんどん元気になるということなんです
これは欲のためでない
ただそれだけの差なんです
だから落ち込んでいくことはありえないんです
落ち込んでいくならば
自分のやり方の方法は間違っているだけ
走ってるんだと言ったっても
人はどこを向いてるんですかということによって変わりますから
ゴールは北にあるならば
西に西の方向を見て あるいは南の方向を見て走ったっても
走っていることは確かに認めますけど
でもゴールからは遠い遠くなるんだと
だから方向性はね ちゃんと決めておかないと
まあそれはサマーディのこと
次に マグガパッチヤ 次はマグガパッチヤ
こういうのをどのように説明すればいいかどうか
マグガっていうのは道ですね
パッチヤっていうのは因ですね
だから道因 これいろんなところでいろんな立場でマグガっていうのは理解しちゃうんで
本当は道っていうのは八正道の道
ことなんですよ 普通の人間の正しく理性に基づいて
理性というか まあとてもこのポジティブ的にラショナル的にね
まあ合理的に生きる偏らないで
何者にも生きる道なんですね
マッガっていうのは で
この瞑想とかなんとかすると
どんどん心は理性的になって合理的になって
すごいもうエネルギーも強くなってきて
統一性もできて それで物事を見ると
普通のサマーディ瞑想の場合は何か掴まるということになってしまっちゃいますけど
すごいことを体験しました
すごいことを体験しましたってことになりますけど
それはすごいことを体験したんではなくて
集中力のおかげで普段体験しないものを体験したんだと
それをたとえで理解してください
で だからこの本見たら
ああ 本見たんだということで
これ顕微鏡で見たら本見えませんね
全く違う 例えばインキの方を見たら点点
点々 黒い点々しか見えません
すごいことを見たんじゃなくて
視覚が強くなっただけなんですね
顕微鏡で見ると そうやって瞑想では普段体験できないものを体験するのはごく普通なことで
集中力というのはもう顕微鏡と同じで
倍率が高ければ高いほど見えてくると
違うもの で そういうものに引っかかって
舞い上がって喜んで やったぞという満足感で生きるんですね
そこはサマーディ世界で
そこら辺で終わってしまっちゃうんですね
仏教はあくまでもクールでクールで冷静で冷静で
それに過ぎてこの何を発見するかと
そのデータを取ったから
取って で そこを持っていくんです
そこで最終的な 本当に論理的に
合理的に 具体的に物事を見えるようになったところで
この道という心が生まれるんです
その心ではもう究極的な強い心であって
で 次の心が生まれると
こちらの影響で煩悩が消えちゃうんです
瞬間の出来事なんですね
だから例えばＡという心があって
その心の次にＢという心が Ｂ
という心には煩悩がなくなっちゃう
なくなるというか また二度と生まれないような状態になってしまっちゃうんです
そこでＢからＣが生まれても Ｄ
が生まれても 何が生まれても
そこに煩悩の働きがなくなっちゃう
もう消えちゃった だからコピーでしょ
心が コピーすることだから
原稿に何か消えちゃったら
コピーにはそれなくなっちゃうんです
そういうことで この道という心があるんですね
4つしかないんだけどね
預流道心と一来道心と不還道心と阿羅漢道心っていう
その心から次に現れるのは果心というんですね
結果の心 それは悟りの心なんですね
そこら辺です 次はもっと分かりやすい原因だと思いますけど
サンパユッタ このサンパユッタパッチェというものは
これサンパユッタっていうのはこの
こちらはそうと書いてますけど
この 入っているとセットになっているんだと
そうするといくらか結果としては変わっちゃうんですね
これもあって これもあって
これもあるという場合と
何かない場合とは問題はちょっと変わるんですね
いい例があります このコンビニエンスストアで弁当を買ったりする
そこでプラスチック製品の箱があって
いろいろ物があって 中に食べられるものもあると
弁当ということになっちゃうんですね
そこでその中身を取り出しちゃったら何になりますかと
嫌なゴミになっちゃうんです
見たくもないゴミ これ美味しい食べたいなと思ったっても
この食べ物は別な入れ物に全部無差別に入れてみてください
食べたくはないんで その場合は
例えば大きなちょっとカップみたいなね
入れ物を持っといて 弁当にあるご飯も他のおかずも全部そこに入れる
入れてみたら 瞬時にして弁当入っていた箱はもう不燃なんて燃えないゴミになってしまっちゃって
もう処分に困ると こちらものは燃えるゴミなんですけど
やっぱり見たら食欲がなくなっちゃうんだと
瞬時に変わるでしょ ただ
どういうことかというと
一緒にある 一緒にないということ
これは一緒にあるという状況
これは一緒にないという状況
言った言っては不相応縁ですね
別に何か変わったわけじゃないんですね
弁当箱は何か突然ご飯が取った瞬間で
いきなり違うものに生まれ変わったわけじゃない
弁当箱は弁当箱で ご飯はご飯で
でもちょっとこの位置が変わっただけで結果が変わってしまった
だからそこで一緒に歩かないかっていうことで影響を与えるんだということ
で 次の 2つはこちらのリピートなんです
アッティパッチェ ナッティパッチェ
アッティっていうのはあるという条件
ナッティっていうのはないという条件
あれのリピートなんです
ダブってるんです ３回言ったことと同じこと
次の 2つ アヴィガタ ヴィガタ
アヴィガタパッチェ ヴィガタパッチェなんですね
アヴィガタ ガタというのは行ってしまった
離れてしまったという意味で
ア入ったら離れてないという条件
ヴィガタというのは離れたという条件ですね
だからまた同じことをリピートされているんです
これは離れてない これは離れている
いわゆる一緒にいるか一緒にいないかって
同じことのリピート だからこれはきちんと整理
されてないんですよ それで十二十四位
で その説明はしたんだけど
まだちょっと理解しにくいところっていうのは
もしかするとこのなぜ条件かなぜ原因かっていうことなんですね
だから最初からもう初期仏教ではそんな区別はなかったんだと
例えばこういうこと たとえで理解してください
紙があって ろうそく 火をつけたろうそくがあるんだ
それでろうそくの炎の原因で紙が燃えるとという因果法則
そこで紙を燃えたいという結果出したければ
原因は必ずしもろうそくの炎になるんですね
そこで条件というのは触れておけと
だから炎に紙が触れたら燃えるんだから
だから炎と紙が触れること
触れるという それは当たり前のことだから
炎があるだけで紙が燃えるわけじゃないんだから
言わなくたってもいいことなんですけど
わざとそれを言ってるだけ
ろうそくの炎の原因で紙が燃える
そこで一緒にいること
触れること あること 離れてないこと
たくさん条件があります
今言った条件全部触れること
あること 離れてないことの条件で
ろうそくの炎から紙の紙が燃えるんだっていう風に言ってるんです
そこはこちらで必死になって言ってることなんです
まあ明確に言ってるというのは明確に言ってることでもなるし
まあ大きな教えという大きな教えでもあるし
で ちょっと例一つ二つ見てみましょう
この例 わかりやすい例選ぶというよりは
もう簡単で番見てみましょう
六種の じゃなくて十六は名は名に対して六種の縁と
で これはどういうことかというと
心から心が原因で心が生まれる
そういうごく一般的な考え方なんですね
心が原因で心が生まれるのは仏教ではもうごく普通の当たり前なことなんですね
そこに六つの条件をつけておくんです
この六つの条件は何ですかというと
アナンテリニルッデ で心の法則知ってますね
心というのは流れですから
一つの心 例えばアビダ昔勉強しましたね
遠い昔 で 例えば一つの心があると
これパーリ語で書いた方が書きやすいんだけど
まあ数字できます 例えばAという心があるとします
その心が滅したところにBという心が生まれるんですね
これを時間通してみると
これ瞬間 瞬間ですね 前の瞬間でAという心があって
その心が消えると次の瞬間でBという心が生まれる
その次の瞬間でBという心が消えると
次の瞬間 例えばCという心が生まれると
で これはシンセツナというものすごい短い時間なんですね
だから心の変化する時間というのは
光の変化のあれよりは倍早いというふうに考えているんだからね
早く変化する それで昔
いろいろ心の変化の道とかたくさん書いてましたからね
例えばチャックビニャーナの次はサンパキッチナという心が
次にはサンティーラナという心
次にはオッタプナという心
次にはジャワナという心
それで即行心の心だわねですね
それは七つ生まれて それからタダーランバナという可笑縁という心で終わっちゃうんだと
ワンセット認識のワンセットとか
そういう説明やったんだから
そこでここ今考えるのは A
という心が生まれる 瞬時に消えてBが生まれる
その場合はどんな条件ですかと
これはどんな心の場合も同じなんです
だから仏教は現在しか物事存在しませんだからいつでも現在ですけど
今の現在の瞬間にある心はちょっと消えちゃうと
すぐにまた心があるんですね
それはそれをその時の現在なんですね
そこでAという心が消える瞬間で
そこにBが生まれる 消えなきゃ生まれません
消えなきゃずっと歩くことそうじゃない
心の寿命は一刹那なんです
一つの瞬間だけ寿命終わるんです
で 消えるんです そこで 6つの原因がある
条件がありますね それ 6つは何でしたっけ？アナンタラパッチエ
アナンタラパッチエって日本語で何でしたっけ？無間因
それから極無間非有非共縁という縁があるんだと
ただそれだけ 無間因縁というのは心一つの心が死ぬと
同じ時間間隔で次の心が生まれるということ
この時間間隔っていうのはもう想像を絶する速さなんですね
どうしても 例えばこの仏教で一般的には説明すると言うでしょ
この指を鳴らす瞬間で
何億も心が生まれて消えていくんだと
すごいもう想像できない速さ
仏教で考えてるんですから
それでも時間の感覚は同じなんですね A
が死ぬ  Bが生まれる ですからアナンタラパッチエと言うんです
時間の感覚は同じだと
それでサマナンタラパッチエとも言うんです
2つ条件 サマナンタラというのは同じ時間の感覚だと
これダブってるんです
同じ言葉が 結局条件 2つ書いてますけど
あるのは1つだけ それからナッティパッチエ
前の心が消えたならば生まれるんだから
前の心が消えたことが次の心の条件になるんですね
だからそれも 1つ条件で言ってるだけ
そういう風にこの 6つありますよ
そこで消えた 消えたこと
またこちら 2つダブってたでしょ
ないという条件と離れて出ていったという条件と
一緒にいない条件 全部ダブってるんだから
その全部入っちゃうんです
似てるものは 大体そういうふうな感じで
全部一つ一つの項目にすっぴってない
喋るんです パッターハというアビダンマの世界では
だから大変な労働的な勉強なんです
重労働の勉強なんです
そういうふうに一般的に言っているわけじゃないんです
例えば よる同身があって
次によるか身が生まれるんですね
よる同身のどんなどんな条件によってよるか身が生まれるかと
この 二十四 はどれどれどれどれどれどれですか？探すんです
それ物質の場合も同じことをそうやって探すんです
探して探して書いて書いて書いて
そこら辺はしっかり書いてますけど
この 十二  二十四 そのものがダブっていることは考えてないんです
二十四 は要りませんと
例えばあるということと一緒にあるということも要りませんし
一つでよろしいし あの無間因と
なんとかもう一つアナンタラパッチョとサマナンタラパッチョと 2つあります
2つ要りません そのたくさんあります
いらないものはダブっているもの
その場合はダブってはいけません
ダブっても構いませんの場合もあります
この場合はやるとはいけませんですけど
ダブってるんですね 今日大体それぐらいでいいと思います
条件の話は  ちょっと質問していいですか？ はいはい
この円の中で時間的にシリアルな感じがする円と
時間的にパラレルな感じがする円があるんです
例えば無限の場合は時間的にシリアルで
サカイッタの場合は時間的シリアル
パラレル場合です そうそうそう
そこでこのずっとそこでから書いているのは
このどれぐらい条件はどんなものにどのように影響を与えているかということ
そこら辺勉強できますけど
このもうすごく覚えておかないと
この今まで勉強したもの
心と身所と あの識の今までやったことは丸暗記していないと難しいんです
ですから そこら辺は一応飛びましょう
飛びまして  二十六 もよく分かりますから
それも飛びまして このこの 二十七
二六八 ページから次回の阿比達磨始まります
二六八 ページのところから始まります
今日はもう時間ないんですが
どうもありがとうございます
はい